as we've watched russia invade ukraine
countries around the world have come
together and levied unprecedented
economic sanctions against the country
we've seen banks get kicked out of the
swift system we've seen oligarchs come
under economic pressure we've also seen
government officials have their assets
frozen and everyday average citizens
unable to withdraw any money from atms
or use their credit cards inside of the
country of russia now of course this
leads to both people in ukraine and also
organizations in the united states
calling for crypto exchanges to put the
same exact pressure economically on
users inside of russia what am i talking
about well we're going to levy these
economic sanctions using swift and
legacy financial system the point is to
apply pressure to the everyday citizen
and hopefully they'll rise up and try to
take putin and his government out of
power but ultimately at the same time
there's a release valve in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and so what a lot of
these folks the ukrainian government
officials the treasury and other
organizations within the us they've gone
to these crypto companies and they said
will you shut down access for all
russian users regardless of whether
they're accused of doing something or
not and what we're watching is that
every single major crypto exchange says
no they are not willing to cut off
financial freedom from the average
innocent russian citizen we've got here
a statement from coinbase that says they
will not comply with the request to ban
russian users saying it would punish
ordinary russian citizens we then got a
statement from binance where they say
they are not going to unilaterally
freeze millions of innocent users
accounts crypto is meant to provide
greater financial freedom for people
across the globe to unilaterally decide
to ban people's access to their crypto
would fly in the face of the reason why
crypto exists now of course if we look
at bitcoin priced in rubles is
absolutely exploding in price much of
that coming because the ruble is in a
free fall these people are experiencing
economic pain that's hard to fathom for
people in the western developed world
ultimately bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
are about financial freedom and what we
are seeing is that without any sort of
legal reason
crypto organizations crypto exchanges
they're not willing to take these users
from russia off the platforms they're
not willing to punish the average
ordinary citizen and it's fascinating to
me that the average russian citizen has
been cut off from the legacy financial
system but the crypto exchanges are
preserving those citizens right to
transact these citizens have nothing to
do with their dictators decisions
they're just as anti-war
they're just as anti-invasion as you and
me these citizens need help
and in their time of need the crypto
exchanges and platforms they're stepping
up they're preserving their right to
transact
and they're preserving their ability to
have some semblance of economic freedom
that's important we must remember
why this was all built
we must continue to preserve our
principles regardless of how unpopular
it is in times like these hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time